tomorrow marks one year since President
Trump moved into the White House with a
very ambitious to-do list he kept his
campaign promise to pack some major tax
reform law but has failed to repeal
Obamacare
he's currently fighting over his pledge
to build a wall along the border with
Mexico major Garrett takes a look at the
president's progress on one of his top
priorities scaling back government
regulations regulations oh boy it's a
lot of regulations President Trump last
month staged an event to show he's
cutting federal regulations complete
with ceremonial scissors 1 2 3
in December the White House said
agencies or Congress undertook quote 22d
regulatory actions for everyone new
regulatory action it's a bit misleading
law professor Kerry colony she heads the
pen program on regulation and says many
of the actions are not as significant as
this White House contends most of those
were either housekeeping matters or
regulations that the Obama
administration started to pull off of
the books the administration can claim
sole credit for these deregulatory moves
the removal of endangered species
protections for Yellowstone grizzly
bears and the rescinding of rules
tightening standards for hydraulic
fracking on public land the joint
resolution is passed
but the republican-led Congress can take
a lot of the credit including repealing
Obama era rules that hadn't yet taken
effect regulations that would have made
it easier to file class-action lawsuits
against banks made it harder for the
mentally ill to buy firearms and protect
waterways from coal mining waste
congratulations mr. president in the
years since taking office the president
has certainly slowed down and in some
cases stopped new regulations we
cancelled or delayed over 1500 planned
regulatory actions more than any
previous president by far but despite
numerous photo ops and public signings
the president still has his work cut out
for him that's great showmanship and it
certainly has convinced a lot of people
that the regulations on the books have
dramatically decreased
under President Trump but they haven't
CBS News chief White House correspondent
that's major Garrett is back again joins
us at the table major you are very
plugged in let's start with a very
Twitter most people are thinking about
shutdown yep how's it looking a White
House officials now say the probability
up to 50% which is highest it's been in
the trouble administration White House
official also says President Trump will
not travel as he had been planning to to
Florida if this is not resolved and I
want to read you a text from one of my
best sources on Capitol Hill who doesn't
traffic in talking points which is why I
like this particular person about the
shutdown this person sends a text to me
a variety of assumptions motivations and
choices have combined to lead everyone
to the edge of a confrontation and no
one expected and have few tools to
forestall absent significant rethinking
these are the hours ladies and gentlemen
where we thinking will be required who's
gonna do it who leads us who leads the
rethinking and where does it need to go
the president needs to rethink and
Democrats on the Senate side need to
rethink or they need to go through their
methodologies of making their point and
then rethink and probably do that in a
very collapsed timeframe if this is
going to be solved by midnight tonight
what does he consider that you know
Donald Trump has said that he's good and
everything the art of the deal is I've
heard that and he's a stable genius what
does he consider the most outstanding or
what what is viewed as the most
significant success he's had in the
1-year anniversary so we just did a
piece on deregulation that would be
right behind this tax bill the President
believes legitimately that that will be
the defining legislative accomplishment
of his first year and maybe for his
entire first term the deregulatory
actions are significant as I talk to
people around the country in business
who look at this administration and say
what's really changed for them they
haven't felt the taxes yet but they felt
the climate where regular federal
regulations changed substantially some
have been withdrawn but they also know
no new ones are coming and for them that
certainty has been an accelerant neither
their business plans to hire or invest
and that climate is fundamentally
different than the Obama administration
let's talk about the wall major yes 70%
of the people don't appear to want this
wall they don't want the whole wall but
for the President Trump this is
meaningful because it's
definitional and it's closed to those
who were most passionate about
supporting him in the first place and he
will not decouple himself from their
desires and that original political
cementing that went on with that base of
his he simply will not he may redefine
what it means how much it costs but he
will press for it relentlessly this
negotiation over the shutdown over Daka
has been a little ragged by even Mitch
McConnell's description that's the White
House give us your sense of the growth
or lack of same in the White House in
terms of just operating the place and
doing the business the president failed
on health care because he could not work
with Republicans and bring them to a
place where they could all agree it's a
much tougher issue for Republicans than
tax cuts but they worked much more
collaboratively the president was
hands-on but in a constructive not
destructive way as he was with health
care that's all great in the Republican
conversation what the president has to
learn now is how to have a conversation
with Democrats one persuasive enough and
durable enough to create compromise if
you had to pick is there gonna be a
shutdown I'm gonna go first nope there's
not gonna be a shutdown what do you say
feels like there'll be a very very short
one maybe just for the weekend just just
I think people need to go on both sides
they need to test each other out mm-hmm
but have us have a resolution that can
manifest itself maybe early Monday all
right major thank you